yeah welcome to yet another 15 minute
game started down a new one immediately
after the last one it was one such a
short game so i'll play and play another
one I think he played this this before
probably the same guy we played this
before against me in them and in a rapid
game okay so first let's go h6 diocese
Bishop what it's doing and then be sure
before I think this is what I played in
the other game as well
hmm
yes you five
in case um if you're asking yourself
what is background noises this is
probably neither the washing machine
that you're hearing I'm sorry I didn't
want to wear that is so loud so what do
we have here my plate III yeah this is
probably am decent move so we are that
just castle first I'm not quite sure I
mean what what black can always do okay
three what you can always do is set up
ahead shock I mean this is always a
decent choice especially if white has
made moves like 92 which are pretty
professor but i'm not sure if I really
want that at this position or start with
the Sun some other moves of course you
can also play d5 opening up the position
which probably isn't too bad as the
night as mentioned this on d 2 that's
not exactly a subtly an active active
posed for the light we need would be
much better on c3 okay but i'll try to
set up in the head shock or maybe i can
play for us should be seven and other
other developing moves and then decide
if i want to make it a pure head shock
yeah probably just Knight f3 or
something yeah this was also an idea but
that wasn't wasn't sure this is really
am a real idea yeah he's probably
intending to take on f6 young and of
course he's attacking the Rockland of
course so well probably I need to play
knight c6 when I was just asking myself
what would happen if you would have
played b4 and b5 this rook hmm ok but he
took on f6 ummm don't know I camera oh I
don't want to have this position with
quince off obviously to not have
problems with my king so he surrendered
the bishop pal for this some de-spawn
weaknesses this this son occurs rather
often in the limbs own with the Quincy
to mostly that the pawn structure he has
changed in this is this fashion normally
black cami doesn't have any particular
problems because of the two bishops
there are simply am good compensation
the question is them yeah how to
continue now I can most play a play slow
move like whoop Dee 8 for example
coverage 7 and then develop the bishop
just should be fine but then I'm asking
myself I have something else something
on bit more active
one idea could be to try to play quickly
against the pawn on c4 when the king is
still on c1 I Bishop a six for example
and then rook c8 sound probably not bad
that one's okay i'll i'll take the
conservative approach that's not clear
that Fisher basics is doing so much in
comparison I can still play but should
be six now so it's not a big problem
that the night is on d6 I can simply
simply also take it and then clicking F
87 and get the rock out again okay so he
wants to threaten me five hmm can I take
and play rook c8 b5 takes takes and then
I've gotta just kind of check with the
night but it doesn't really a lead to
anything so probably take an ID five
this looks good
yeah to attack to attack the sea phone
you see porn immediately and I'm not
sure how I yeah I think he needed to do
that and yeah I could just retreat that
yet the bishop is good on b7 and this
pawn structures it's not very flexible
I'm just threatening rook c8 now I pick
up the pawn rook c8 rook d4 d5 and it's
gone and also Knight g4 I some move that
needs to be reckoned with ok Knight g4 I
can play roop d2 we are all night h3 so
I'm ok let's attack this pawn
you
okay so uh haha maybe I could have have
cliff taken at last move I'm just
recognizing the idea night see for
Bishop c4 Bishop g2 and I'll win the
rook in the corner and then probably I
could have plated one move earlier even
this is really is this really working
let's check again Knight takes bishop
takes Bishop g2 can probably try to trap
it on on h1 but I get it I get this i
get the rook it's not where he can
prevent that funny I'd I want two pawns
in the process so it's not a big deal if
you trap the bishop reading what funny
yeah and he cannot really i mean if he
doesn't take yeah he doesn't it the
rupee saying i take the rook now white
resigns yeah I can't get a quick game a
quick game what can I do um yeah but I
think it did it was it was gone now here
he needs to retreat the rook probably as
this is really losing just just scrap
the rook and this means that i could
have instead of roots yet i could have
taken immediately now but i only spotted
that one move one wolf later yeah i
think i was what's all right but here
here before I completely ignored this
idea and this is tricky now be five
play this know something like this maybe
this is still still okay with this this
really weird maneuver yeah it looks
completely crazy with the Jeep on but
what can you do yeah I simply I simply
didn't didn't appreciate the before idea
this is probably what you should have
played before the end this end game
transposition is not a big problem for
black with the water with the doubled
pawns as we saw and it was even a quick
win but only with her from the opponent
yeah thanks for watching